[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña elvis garcía doctor en salud
pública por la universidad de harvard y
profesor de epidemias para hablar sobre
el panorama que se está viviendo en
europa en cuanto a la vacunación contra
el kobe 19 las clases de vacunas ha
ocasionado el retraso en los procesos de
inoculación en los países de la unión
europea doctor le pregunto si podrán las
farmacéuticas cumplir con las 200 de 210
millones de dosis que se han
comprometido a entregar a los países del
bloque antes de que finalice el mes de
junio
bueno ahora hay algo fundamental que nos
ha entendido creo bien y es que la
producción de una vacuna es
extremadamente compleja los controles de
calidad lo que están sometidas estas
cadenas de producción son muy estrictos
lo que es muy bueno pero esto implica
que sobre todo al principio surjan estos
retrasos esto es normal lo que ocurre es
que hay que ajustar expectativas pero
nunca pasa que nuestros líderes
políticos por lo general no entienden
cómo funciona este estos procesos tienen
a pecar de optimistas y se lanzan a
estos titulares llamativos de vamos a
vacunar a 100 millones de personas pero
yo creo que eso no ayuda hay que ser un
poco más realistas hay que entender que
estos retrasos son normales y de nuevo
hay que ajustar expectativas que es
difícil dar predicciones sobre si se va
a poder tener 200 millones de vacunas
para el verano o para junio
a este aliado y no podemos saberlo pero
yo creo que al principio estos retrasos
son normales y a medida que avancemos
la velocidad de producción y de
aprovisionamiento se estabilizará y se
cumplirá mejor los plazos ahora hablemos
de lo que ha pasado en algunos países en
españa por ejemplo se ha registrado una
disparidad en el número de vacunas que
se entregan a las regiones
estas diferencias qué consecuencias
traerá para los intereses en el proceso
de inmunización a nivel nacional
como en realidad lo que está pasando en
estos países en los que nos ha llevado
una estrategia centralizada de la
gestión de la vacunación es que hay
disparidades entre regiones porque cada
región vacuna como les viene en gana
esto es un error este es un error que se
debería de evitar porque así vamos a
dejar de zonas sin protección dentro de
un país y dentro de un país hay mucha
movilidad lo que puede hacer es que el
virus siga circulando y como bien
sabemos cuanto más circula más
oportunidades hay de que hayan
mutaciones dentro del virus así que
tenemos en cuenta hay que tener en
cuenta que hay gente que no puede
vacunarse y esta gente solo se protege
si hay inmunidad de grupo para conseguir
esta inmunidad el grupo hay que vacunar
casi al 70% de la población es decir no
es una manera una meta fácil de alcanzar
y esto sólo se alcanzará si tenemos si
evitamos errores en la gestión una vez
que tengamos las vacunas que es lo
difícil lo que no podemos es cerrar a la
hora de distribuirlas dentro de un
propio país eso es inaceptable
ahora doctor hablando de esa
inmunización colectiva al preocupación
por el escepticismo de algunas personas
por ejemplo en francia ante la vacuna
cual tendría que ser entonces la
estrategia de los países para lograr la
inmunidad ante esta reacción de algunos
ciudadanos de no vacunarse que le dice
además usted a estas personas
es verdad que es conocido como bien dice
es que países como francia hay un gran
escepticismo hacia las vacunas
personalmente yo creo que en este caso
será un poco distinto a lo que conocemos
de por ejemplo de la campaña de
vacunación de la gripe donde muy poca
gente se vacuna porque será distinto yo
creo que esa vez la gente está sufriendo
en sus carnes el impacto de la
enfermedad y los escépticos verán que
cientos de millones de personas se están
vacunando y no está ocurriendo nada
negativo no hay efectos secundarios
doces se creará un efecto de bola de
nieve donde la gente se irá sumando poco
a poco por otro lado también hay medidas
como lo que se comenta de un pasaporte
inmunitario un pasaporte de vacunas eso
puede incentivar a aquellos indecisos
sin necesidad de hacerla obligatoria
pero sí haciéndoles que teniendo ese
pasaporte inmunitario se les haga la
vida más fácil no entonces yo creo que
irá en esta línea
así estructura al final de cuentas pues
hay que confiar en la ciencia y batallar
contra esta pandemia de coronavirus que
a todos nos ha afectado de alguna u otra
manera gracias por estar con nosotros en
este espacio
de france 24 5 minutos con era el doctor
elvis garcía doctor en salud pública de
la universidad de harvard y también
profesor de epidemias aquí este espacio
de cinco minutos hace una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]